well you are looking live now at images
from our southern border high over the
rio grande river and eagle pass where in
the seven days i was there there were
more than 11 000
encounters with migrants today there
have been upwards of
1700 and it comes as they're trying to
struggle with a record number of illegal
crossings now this as texas governor
greg abbott reacts to the supreme court
giving president biden the green light
to end the trump era remain in mexico
policy avid writing the supreme court's
decision upholding dhs's termination of
the remain in mexico policy will only
embolden the biden administration's open
border policies we were able to speak
earlier this week with the governor down
along the riverbank here's some of our
exclusive interview
let's talk about just how bad the
situation is right now in your state
so it literally has never been worse and
it's never been worse because the
numbers are higher than they've ever
been the the problems and challenges are
mounting on the other side of the border
but worst of all we are not seeing the
president lift a finger to do anything
about it and it's like we're some
abandoned outpost out here and the
president has abandoned one of the
states actually many of the states all
the border states of the united states
of america is reprehensible and we saw
the tragedy this week in san antonio
what was your reaction when you first
learned about that what needs to be done
now well the first reaction is shock i
mean you can't be anything but shocked
and stunned whenever you hear or see
anything like that
and it is a horrific tragedy but it also
is a byproduct of biden's border
policies
when you don't have a president who's
actually forcing the immigration laws it
attracts the cartels and smugglers to do
exactly what they did that led to this
disaster and that's why we're calling
upon the president to finally finally
step up and do your job and secure the
border and enforce the immigration laws
and you are announcing some additional
steps that you will take texas will take
to try and prevent tragedies like the
one we saw
so first to explain the context of it
and that is one reason why the tragedy
occurred is because there was
insufficient border patrol officers to
be able to inspect every vehicle that
was coming up that highway this vehicle
that had the people in it who passed
away was not inspected and so what texas
is doing is we're deploying additional
texas department of public safety
officers
to check some of these commercial
vehicles to do our part to try to
prevent tragedies like what happened in
san antonio you talk about republicans
how important do you think this is is an
issue as we head into the midterms it's
a game changer it was one of the things
that led to the victory for myra flores
not too far from where we are right now
this territory on the border used to
always
be dominated by democrats and now we
have the first mexican-born hispanic
woman elected as a republican to the
united states congress in the rio grande
valley and it shows the paramount
importance of border security issues
that she campaigned on
that of course a border community
but for voters well north of the border
in northeast states and beyond should
they care
they do care and i'll tell you one
reason why i mean that first of all they
don't like seeing their border overrun
they don't like seeing the lawlessness
but also
many of these people who are coming
across the border are flown into their
states but then on top of that and
perhaps worse the fentanyl is making it
this way to their states also
communities on in northern u.s and
eastern u.s and western u.s are all
infiltrated with this very deadly
fentanyl the border crisis
is
having an effect on every state in the
united states do you think with the way
these numbers have been surging i
remember just last year we would have a
group of 100 that they classified the
border patrol as a large group since
i've been here for five days we've had a
group of three or four hundred every
single day can we sustain this
with with the the inadequate personnel
that are being provided on the federal
side it'll be more difficult but that's
exactly why i was here today to announce
more strategies of what texas is doing
about laying down more reservoirs
building more barriers adding more
troops and personnel to these regions
where you see a high influx of people
coming across the border texas adds
people to help solve this problem
whereas the united states is not
we know as we sit here along the banks
of the rio grande the cartel is watching
is this crisis
benefiting them in ways that we have
never seen
they make money off of everybody who
comes across the border they made money
off the people who lost their lives in
that truck and one of our goals is to
use strategies that will cause the
cartels to lose money in texas
governor
finally
and this is a open-ended question but
how does this end
it it ends with the federal government
finally doing his job it probably is
going to end with a new president but it
can end far quicker than that because i
think the republicans can gain control
of congress in just a few months uh and
they can begin the hearings that may
lead to the impeachment of secretary
morcus and finally hold the button
administration accountable for their
lawlessness on the united states border
governor abbott thank you for your time
thank you